المشهد مروع حيث يبحث رجال الإنقاذ
بشكل محموم بين الحطام
بحثًا عن ناجين على أمل
العثور على أي يتلاشى في الثانية مع
تقدم الليل البارد
بالنسبة للبعض ، فإن الحزن أكثر من أن
تتحمله شنايا تقول إنها مرت بهذا المبنى
قبل حوالي نصف ساعة فقط
هناك العديد من الأصدقاء والأشخاص
المقربين مني هنا العديد منهم تقول
إيلينا لويان أذهلت من حجم
الدمار اللعنات الروس
أنا أكرههم ببساطة الأطفال مات الناس
هنا ومن ثم لا يمكننا التحدث بعد الآن
فوق القتلى الكثيرين
تقول السلطات الأوكرانية إن العشرات أصيبوا وما
زال الكثيرون في عداد المفقودين في هذا
الموقع الوحيد في نيبرو بعد أن ضربت روسيا
مواقع عبر أوكرانيا بوابل من
الصواريخ في نهاية هذا الأسبوع.
-22 هو صاروخ كروز
مصمم عادة لتدمير
حاملات الطائرات برأس حربي يزيد عن
2000 رطل ، وكما ترون فإنه
مطلق  دمرت بالكامل مبنى
دفن عشرات الأشخاص تحت
روسيا ولم يعلق بشكل مباشر على
الضربة القاتلة في نيبرو لكن في الماضي
رفضت موسكو استهداف قواتها
للمناطق السكنية التي يطلق عليها الأوكرانيون
الهجوم إرهاب الدولة
ويقول الرئيس إن رجال الإنقاذ سيستمرون في
محاولة الإنقاذ.  أي شخص محاصر هنا
، فلنقاتل من أجل كل شخص
يقول الرئيس زيلينسكي إن عملية الإنقاذ
ستستمر طالما أن هناك
أدنى فرصة لإنقاذ الأرواح
ولكن حتى أدنى أمل يتلاشى
بسرعة وقد يتحول هذا قريبًا من عملية
إنقاذ إلى عملية تعافي.  طاقم
يبحث عن الجثث حيث
تم إنهاء أرواح العديد من الأشخاص بعنف في لحظة
لأخذ CNN nipro Ukraine